[Musik]
herzlich willkommen bei bild affen
pocken ja allein dieses wort erzeugt
doch angst bei uns und dann erst die
bilder davon von den symptomen bilder
die uns erschrecken seit einigen tagen
denn es gibt mittlerweile ja auch die
ersten bestätigten fälle davon in
deutschland erst einer in münchen dann
mehrere mittlerweile in berlin die
weltgesundheitsorganisation die jetzt
massiv warnt und maßnahmen gegen diese
affen pocken fordert ebenso der us
präsident joe biden wie gefährlich sind
diese affen pocken die richtigen fragen
jetzt an gerhard treiber den arzt
obdachlosen arzt ein mann der das
bundesverdienstkreuz trägt weil er sich
vor allen dingen um arme kümmert in
seiner eigenschaft als arzt ein mann der
bei der bundespräsidentenwahl gegen
frank walter steinmeier angetreten ist
herzlich willkommen an sie herzlich
willkommen an gunter frank allgemeinarzt
aus heidelberg ein mann der genau weiß
wie im moment die patienten mit solchen
neuen schreckensmeldungen umgeht und der
die deutsche politik immer kritisiert
hat als eine die nie richtig war erwin
rüddel es bei uns zugeschaltet der mann
der die rechte hand dieser corona
politik die rechte hand von jens spahn
auf dem höhepunkt der korona krise war
als chef des gesundheitsausschusses
damals herzlich willkommen auch ihnen
erwin rüddel und gleich in der sendung
auch der bayerische gesundheitsminister
klaus holetschek also der mann der den
ersten bestätigten affen pocken fall in
seinem bundesland in bayern gerade
managen muss herr frank affen pocken ich
habe es gerade schon gesagt dieses wort
allein dass er erzeugt angst wie nehmen
dass ihre patientin aktuell war also
über meinen patienten ist es noch wenig
angekommen aber ich fürchte wenn dieses
diese ich würde es fast schon wieder
panikmache dazu sagen weiterläuft dann
werden patienten eben nachfragen die
gefährliches ist was man dagegen tun
kann und das ist halt wieder mal so ein
beispiel dass man heute mit bildern mit
schlagzeilen angst erzeugen kann die
einfach ihr realer kam die patienten
jetzt schon zu ihnen hat schon der ein
oder andere angerufen hat gesagt was ist
das da muss ich mir sorgen machen wie
schätzen sie das eine frage aus dem
bekanntenkreis
aber
ich denke es kommt darauf an wie
mediales aufbereitet wird das corona
ähnlich dann wird das eben auch die
menschen weiter und verunsichert in so
einem angst level auch halten und es
wird halt wieder einmal darum gehen dass
man die relationen nicht warte also wie
gefährlich ist das eigentlich ist das
überhaupt eine reale bedrohung für den
neu ist sage ich mal durchschnittlichen
mensch noch das wollen wir rausfinden in
dieser sendung es gibt diese warnungen
ja aber und die kommen von niemand
geringerem als unter anderem von der
weltgesundheitsorganisation die noch mal
eindringlich warnt auch heute noch
einmal nach einer sitzung dort aktuell
in genf die ja tatsächlich jetzt fordert
die sagte ich mache mir sorgen dass sich
die übertragung beschleunigen könnte das
eben die spitze der
weltgesundheitsorganisation die das
genauso einschätzt und jetzt massiv nach
massnahmen ruft herr ude erinnert sie
das alles ein bisschen an die anfänge
corona alles schon mal da gewesen so ein
bisschen in diesem moment
also die erinnerungen kommen wieder
zumal man am anfang auch der meinung war
dass das corona virus eigentlich lokal
begrenzte aktiv sei und dann wurde es
mehr aber ich denke auf der anderen
seite die die wissenschaft ist
sensibilisiert die politik ist
sensibilisiert und die menschen sind
auch sensibilisiert und es wäre denke
ich jetzt ein fehler
panik zu verbreiten sondern wir müssen
realistisch in die zukunft schauen
aufmerksam sein
aufklären und
versuchen alle möglichkeiten die das
gesundheitssystem bietet zu nutzen aber
sie haben dieses deshalb möchte erlebnis
gerade ja wenn wir zweieinhalb jahre
zurückblicken auch hören was hat die
politik da gesagt sie an dieses déjà vu
erlebnis gerade in diesen tagen
also man denkt automatisch an
johann und china aber auf der anderen
seite wenn man sich mit den affen
pockenviren beschäftigt dann merkt man
dass also hier sicherlich keine
vergleiche gezogen werden wir können und
auf der anderen seite wie gesagt das
gesundheitssystem die menschen deutlich
sehen sie in sensibilisierter sind als
last bei corona am anfang war er trat
ich hab gerade schon gesagt sie arbeiten
wirklich an der basis machen ganz ganz
wichtigen job einen der aber in ganz
vielen stunden auch sehr hart sein kann
wo man sehr vieles auch sieht
schreckliche bilder sicherlich auch
sieht kann sie sowas schrecken was wir
hier gerade zeigen auch die bilder von
diesen massiven symptom als die
symptomatik aktuell von den fällen in
deutschland ist ja bei weitem nicht so
stark wie es heißt aber schreckt sie so
was
mich schreckt das im prinzip nicht und
doch und zwar mich schreckt es immer
wieder dass von solchen
infektionserkrankungen die besonders
menschen betroffen sind die in armut
leben also weltweit aber auch bei uns
und das ist eine strukturelle
benachteiligung gibt von menschen die
wenig finanzielle ressourcen haben die
wenig für ihre gesunderhaltung tun
können die sich nicht gut ernähren
können die nicht für hygiene sorgen
können die beengt leben oder auf der
straße leben das ist für mich so ein
déjà vu jetzt ja corona jetzt diese
infektionskrankheit und dass auch viele
andere infektionskrankheiten die ist bei
uns nicht so gibt dass es für die
malaria keinen impfstoff gibt aber
millionen von menschen darunter leiden
also ihre patienten schafft ihre
kundschaft die muss so etwas ausbauen
ja in gewissem maße schon sie muss es
insofern ausbaden dass diese menschen
häufig nicht im fokus auch der
politischen entscheidungsträger stehen
sie stehen so ganz weit hinten das haben
wir ja auch bei corona gesehen ein
kollege von mir professor tradinno hat
eine untersuchung durchgeführt und
festgestellt dass es besonders empfänger
von arbeitslosengeld 2 sind die eine
hohe infektionsrate hatten und einen
schweren verlauf also insofern sind
besonders auch von armut betroffene
menschen in deutschland und weltweit
betroffen das vertiefen wir gleich noch
herr riedel wir haben nochmal drüber
gesprochen über das was im moment
erstmal von weltgesundheitsorganisation
kommt was auch an beschädigt kann man
sich jetzt politiker jetzt in dieser
zeit hinstellen sie werden sich sehr
genau erinnern wie das bei ihnen war vor
zweieinhalb jahren und sagen der
bevölkerung hier in deutschland kein
grund zur sorge wir haben das ding im
griff
so eine äußerung zu tätigen das hat man
in der anime corona angeli gelernt wir
haben das im griff da sollte man sehr
zurückhaltend sein genau den satz hat
damit armin laschet gesagt damals ja
noch ministerpräsident in nordrhein
westfalen damals dann auf dem weg zur
spitzenkandidat kandidatur zur
bundestagswahl hat genau das gesagt wir
haben das ding im griff ja
wir haben lernen müssen dass wir viele
aussagen wie ihren mussten im laufe der
korona pandemie wobei ich heute glaube
dass man also mit größter zuversicht in
den sommer herbst und winter sehen kann
weil wir gelernt haben mit dem virus
umzugehen hier sehe ich eigentlich eine
große herausforderung dass wir den
menschen wieder die
eigenverantwortung zurück geben sie aber
auch entsprechend fähig machen mit
dieser eigenschaft aller
eigenverantwortlich mit corona umzugehen
hier haben wir mit den affen pocken
denke ich eine neue herausforderung wird
ja auch angesprochen dass man verwundert
ist über die infektiosität her aber oft
nimmt wir müssen wissen und das denke
ich ist das wichtigste
ändern sich übertragungswege wenn sich
die übertragungswege nicht ändern
sollten glaube ich müssen wir uns keine
so großen sorgen machen weil halt eben
die übertragung corona oder affen pocken
sehr sehr unterschiedlich ist enge
körperkontakt
müssen vorhanden sein um alle das ist
ein interessanter punkt sie haben gerade
gerade angesprochen die warnungen auch
sie haben die charité hier zitiert die
sich ebenfalls verwundert zeigt aktuell
über die schnelle ausbreitung über die
hohe infektiosität wie sie es gerade
nennen und gleichzeitig haben sie gesagt
wie er oft man sich vor einigen die
politik aber auch die behörden ihrer
eigenen aussagen revidieren musste in
der korona krise gefragt wenn wir das
zusammen mixen und jetzt sehen wir diese
bilder von diesen affen pocken symptomen
sehen die ersten heftigen warnung von
der charité von der
weltgesundheitsorganisation und jetzt
nochmal zu ihren patienten glauben die
das dann was die spitzenpolitik sagt an
möglicherweise entwarnung auch erstmal
an beschwichtigung oder eben auch die
warnung von der
weltgesundheitsorganisation was soll der
normalbürger jetzt der anfang der
gelernt hat dass kann sich innerhalb von
wochen drehen also meine patienten sind
informiert dass man diesen warnungen
doch erstmal ein bisschen misstrauen
sollte das hat ja auch eine
vorgeschichte bis die geht bis zur
schweinegrippe zurück
wichtig ist folgendes wenn eine epidemie
ausbricht muss man die werkzeuge
einsetzen die dazu geeignet sind die
gefährlichkeit zu ermitteln die für
infektions sterblichkeit unter gleichen
und das sind eben konsequente
repräsentative kohortenstudien klingt
etwas technisch aber das ist das was
jede gute wahl forschung macht wenn sie
versucht ein wahlergebnis vorauszusagen
sie sucht sie eine stichprobe die
deutschland repräsentiert und kann so
ziemlich genau voraussagen wie gewählt
wird und so muss man das machen und das
hat man bei corona von anfang an nicht
gemacht das ist ein ich würde wirklich
historisches versagen des robert koch
instituts dazu sagen das wurde immer
wieder angemahnt von leuten wie matthias
schrappe oder auch gerd antes das sind
führende epidemiologen mit weltweit
weltweite reputation und es wurde nicht
gemacht also es kommt es darauf an diese
affen brocken haben einen ganz anderen
würde schon sagt er ganz anderen
ansteckungswege es hat hoch
wahrscheinlich nicht die potenz eine
wirkliche pandemie zu werden in diesem
sinne aber da muss man einfach gute
studien gute instrumente haben um das
eben zu ermitteln bei corona ist die
situation eine ganz andere wir sind am
ende der pandemie und wir haben harte
zahlen wir brauchen keine studien mehr
und wir brauchen auch keine
modellrechnungen her wir haben die
harten zahlen und die sind eindeutig und
ich wundere mich immer noch dass wir
nicht öffentlich darüber sprechen
nämlich diese hatten zahlen zeigen wir
haben maßlos übertrieben zurück zum
affen pocken thema noch zunächst wir
vertiefen das andere nachher auch noch
in der in dieser sendung aber jetzt ist
ja ganz spannend wie wir mit diesen
behörden warnungen hier in deutschland
umgehen sie sagen jetzt robert koch
institut hat einen geradezu historischen
fehler begangen jetzt ist dasselbe ist
robert koch institut die aber zuständig
uns dafür aufzuklären wie es mit dem
affen pockenvirus hier in deutschland
man muss halt jetzt eine repräsentative
studie am laufen haben dann kann man
sehen ob das überhaupt einen massen
thema wird werden wahrscheinlich nicht
und da man ja schon ziemlich genau weiß
welche gruppe sich infiziert muss man
auf diese gruppe zu gehen und sie
entsprechend informieren und es wird
hoch wahrscheinlich nicht da gibt es
ganz andere gefahren
hoch wahrscheinlich wird das mittel für
die gesellschaft werden er wurde hier
gibt es zweifel daran ob das so gut
geschieht ob die aufklärung die
informationen so gut geschieht seitens
des robert-koch-instituts ja auf
erfahrung basiert wie das gelaufen ist
in der korona krise also sind die in der
lage sind die richtigen um jetzt in
sachen affen pocken uns gut zu
informieren und rechtzeitig zu warnen
also ich denke das robert koch institut
das paul ehrlich institut die
wissenschaft insgesamt haben uns gut
beraten wir oder wie heißt der banker
war ganz anders ja also ich stimme herrn
frank auch in der hinsicht zu dass wir
zu vorsichtig in die antriebs oder uns
zu vorsichtig in der an demi verhalten
haben man hätte ich früher mehr auf
eigenverantwortung
setzen können und auf normalität und ich
hoffe dass das jetzt also zügig in den
nächsten monat auf den weg gebracht wird
quasi keine prognose ist eingetreten das
robert koch instituts konnte mit jeder
prognose lag man massiv daneben ja aber
ich glaube da waren wir uns in der
politik aber weitestgehend auch einig
lieber einen weg zu gehen mit vorsicht
als experimente zu gehen den anderen
ländern war man da mutiger das gebe ich
zu und jetzt im nachhinein haben wir
festgestellt auch was also über
sterblichkeit angeht was die über
sterblichkeit in deutschland höher war
als in ländern die also früher geöffnet
haben und zur normalität zurückgekehrt
sind wir
müssen das evaluieren bewerten und wir
müssen dann auch feststellen wer hier
wann
entscheidungen getroffen hat die man
besser hätte treffen können aber
grundsätzlich
möchte ich die wissenschaft das ak ii
und das paul ehrlich institut in schutz
nehmen die haben die politik rang sehr
gut beraten hätte ich vernehme dass wir
wirklich wohlwollend dass sie jetzt
sagen wir haben da ein bisschen
überzogen und so weiter aber so ist es
ja nun mal nichts man hat nicht ein
bisschen überzogen sondern hat
katastrophal überzogen wir hatten mit
maßnahmen reagiert die weit mehr schaden
angerichtet haben als das virus hier
gekonnt hätte ja wir haben den kindern
teilweise ihre bildung genommen wir
haben leute in
existenznöte gebracht wir haben auch die
gesellschaft gespalten und wir haben das
muss man auch einfach mal wissen wir
haben durch unsere lockdown eine
hungersnot in afrika mit ausgelöst und
dass das müssen wir bearbeiten wir
müssen das wirklich nachschauen genau
was da gelaufen und das muss auch ein
bundesgesundheitsminister darf das nicht
verhindern also nochmal ich will dass
ich will das mal die zahl nennen weil
das ist wirklich wichtig was ist denn
nun die eigentliche kennziffer von
corona wie viel co wie kranke waren in
den krankenhäusern weiß noch immer hieß
das will man verhindern die überlastung
des systems und dann ist es eben so dass
das müsste in ihrer fraktion ja auch
besprochen worden sein die leipzig
analyse gezeigt hat wir hatten eine
historische unterbelegung der
krankenhäuser auch der intensivabteilung
die wahren unterbelegt das problem dort
ist der personalmangel aber das ist ein
politik politik versagen und nicht von
dieser unterbelegung der krankenhäuser
waren nur zwei prozent hatten die kurve
diagnose bekommen und da kann man jetzt
echt nicht hergehen und kann sagen dass
das irgend eine außergewöhnliche
medizinische bedrohung war das war s
nicht durchschnittsalter der gestorbenen
83 jahre aber wenn wenn wir das hören
und unseren umgang mit corona noch
einmal reflektieren den letzten
zweieinhalb jahren wenn jetzt das
nächste auf den tisch kommt wir reden
jetzt über affen pocken hat uns corona
gelehrt gelassener mit alldem umzugehen
oder umso alarmierter umso mehr mit
angst um so mehr mit panik also ich will
jetzt gar nicht dann in die diskussion
noch wer was wann richtig falsch gemacht
hat das war eine außergewöhnliche
situation die hat es noch nie gegeben
obwohl wir wissen als mediziner sowas
kommt immer wieder alle 80 bis 100
jahren gibt es eine pandemie für mich
ist mir dass das thema ich habe sie
jetzt wieder gehört eigenverantwortung
wie kann ich dann eigenverantwortung
übernehmen wenn ich einfach nicht die
finanziellen ressourcen habe um mich zu
schützen um mir genügend sp2 masken zu
kaufen um mich gesund zu ernähren all
diese wenig verengt leben muss die
kinder ja die kinder wurden
benachteiligt im homeschooling weil
viele kinder eben kein laptop kein
internetzugang er und keinen drucker
hatten also für mich ist immer wieder
das thema und da hat auch das buch oder
da hat das robert-koch-institut versagt
dass die menschen am rande unserer
gesellschaft nicht gesehen werden und
sie müssen im fokus stehen denn sie sind
besonders gefährdet machen wir einmal
den test zum beispiel sie haben
herausgefunden was was hat alleine die
bundesregierung was hat der staat
bezahlt für die ganzen tests die
kostenlos ausgegeben wurden völlig
corona test die schätzungen sind für
2021 14 milliarden und das ist ja auch
der punkt den sie gesagt haben es war
doch von anfang an klar und das war
wirklich also ich möchte dass der
wissenschaftler jedes nennen es war von
anfang an klar wer die risikogruppe ist
bei dieser saisonalen atemwegs
reaktionen die ihre besonderheiten hatte
definitiv und wenn man sich darauf
fokussiert hätte wenn man diese 14
milliarden zum beispiel einen teile
ihnen gegeben hätte sie hätten damit was
anfangen können sie hätten die was wenn
sie mit 14 milliarden machen der trabert
sehr viel aber ich würde denkt man
vielleicht nicht ich will erstmal den
hartz-iv-satz erhöhen so ihr habt das
nicht mehr das gesundheitsbudget für
einen hartz-iv-empfänger bei 17 eur 30
liegt sondern höher dann kann ich auch
mehr für die gesundheit tun ich würde
auch unser gesundheitssystem
modifizieren wir brauchen nicht das
duale system privat und gesetzlich das
führt immer wieder zu halten viele
menschen können überhaupt nicht mehr das
in anspruch nehmen was unser
gesundheitssystem anbietet wenn ich
keine sehhilfe ab dem 18 lebensjahr
lebensjahr mehr von den krankenkassen
bekommen was ist denn das für ein system
also ich würde an ganz anderen punkten
ansetzen salutogenese die
gesundheitsförderung die muss gefördert
werden prävention wir sind ja auch in
brennpunkte gegangen in die teestube
haben die menschen aufgeklärt und haben
sie dort versorgt und geimpft also
aufsuchende niedrigschwelliger
medizinische angebote und die basis muss
verbessert werden und die basis bedeutet
haben wir da gelernt aus corona also
hebt die schlüsse gezogen überhaupt
nicht das ist ja ein skandal dass der
hartz iv satz um drei euro erhöht wurde
am ersten und jetzt sollen 200 euro als
ausgleich gezahlt werden das reicht noch
nicht mal um die inflationsrate zur nur
auszugleichen und also hier sind die
menschen weiterhin strukturell
benachteiligt und gesundheitsgefährdend
und panik und angst kann nie ein die
grundlage guter mediziner guter politik
sein ich mache was ist denn passiert
durch diese ganze mediale panik diese
ständigen todeszahlen die ja hatte
vergessen zu sagen dass das teil des
ganz normalen sterbe geschehens war aber
täglich tote tote ist folgendes passiert
man hat dann zum beispiel in ein
altersheim auf panik bekommen man hat
alte menschen mit den effekt in die
krankenhäuser getan jetzt einen ein 85
jähriger multimorbider patient mit
geschichte mit schlaganfällen er hat
nichts mehr von einem akutkrankenhaus
dort will man leben retten aber das
stück verlieren kann nur das sterben
dann kommen darf intensiv dann wird er
beatmet völlig sinnlos das sind sachen
passiert ist nicht in ordnung das müssen
wir alles aufrüttelte haben ja gesagt
pflege ja die pflege wir haben ja wenig
pflegekräfte das ist sowas strukturelles
der hätte die politik schon längst
handeln und ist offenbar steht auch
immer mehr oder weniger hilflos davor
denn das problem erkannt da verbindet
haus jede tausende beatmungsgeräte
bestellt die verstauben irgendwo hier im
keller in berlin anstatt pflegekräfte ja
zu rekrutieren punkte sehr hoch
interessant kommt hier aus der runde
hertel jetzt stehen wir zweieinhalb
jahre nach den ersten corona fällen hier
und in deutschland und reden eben über
das nächste virus das ganz anders ist
aber da ist uns eben wieder sorge macht
und wir wollen wissen was sind für
schlüsse gezogen worden und jetzt stellt
die runde fest nicht die richtigen oder
keine schlüsse wer ist eigentlich dafür
verantwortlich die verantwortlichen sind
ja weg der gesundheitsminister ist ein
anderer und also wer wer steht dafür
gerade
also zum beispiel haben wir heute
deutlich mehr pflegekräfte als wir vor
der pandemie hatten also da steht ja für
rhade lassen ja ich ist mir bewusst aber
würden geeinigt als werden alles
schlechter geworden wäre wir haben nie
eine überforderung des
gesundheitssystems gehabt und wir werden
analysieren und evaluieren müssen wer
welche verantwortlichkeit
tragen muss aber wer macht das gerade
ich nehme das überhaupt nicht wahr ich
nehme wahr dass da gerade studien oder
evaluierung gerade gerade nicht
stattfinden aber wer macht das jetzt so
wer schreibt daran den lag das müssen
wir ändern also ich möchte nicht jetzt
schuldzuweisungen machen an alte
regierung neue regierung glaube aber
dass man aus den fehlern die eventuell
in der alten regierung gemacht worden
sind weil man zu vorsichtig war daraus
lernen müsste dass man jetzt schneller
zur normalität kommt und das glaube ich
kann man also deutlich verantworten
diese weitere normalität und
entspannt hat ja zu beginn der pandemie
gesagt wir werden uns am ende bei vielen
menschen entschuldigen müssen aber wir
wissen heute noch nicht bei wie vor
allem handarbeit hat schon das gesagt
verdient hat gesagt vor allen dingen bei
denen sozial schwachen bei den beiden in
beengten verhältnissen leben bei ihnen
ja auch nachgewiesen die todeszahlen und
die zahlen der schweren erkrankungen
besonders hoch waren das ist eine gruppe
bei der man sich entschuldigen muss und
da sagt herter aber da sind bisher keine
schlüsse daraus gezogen wurde hat sich
nichts geändert so ich war aber ich
denke ich ich denke man muss sich
zuallererst bei unseren kindern
entschuldigen weil wir sie zu sehr
eingeschränkt haben wir stehen an einer
zeitenwende
und ich glaube wir müssen die
sozialpolitik grundsätzlich auf den
prüfstand stellen ob wir über dies kann
erreichen was wir erreichen wollen das
was er trat sarah oder der aspekt wir
müssen solidarisch sein wir müssen aber
auch das
prinzip hilfe zur selbsthilfe stärker in
den vordergrund bringen dh jeder muss im
armen seiner kräfte einen beitrag
leisten damit er das leben kommt und
damit würden wir wahrscheinlich
mittel einsparen um die besonders
schwachen in der gesellschaft zu
unterstützen
also ich glaube es ist nicht getan damit
noch mehr geld in richtung sozialpolitik
auszugeben sondern wir müssen gerade in
der zeit in der wir jetzt hier stehen
dass das also entlastungen an vielen
stellen notwendig sind inflationen die
folgen der pandemie
wir wissen noch nicht was also an folgen
kommt durch nico ketten unterwegs
dazwischen unter die lassen sie uns noch
einmal konzentriert zum thema affen
pocken gleich zurück kommen aber er
fragt kurz dagegen und auch er traf also
ich brauche keine zeitenwende ich
brauche die anwendung bewährter
standards die man mit füßen getreten hat
bei kronau ja es ist doch der ärztliche
grundsatz dass eine therapie nicht mehr
schaden darf als die krankheit selbst
und jetzt mal das thema impfungen ja ich
sagen in der pflege ist alles besser ich
meine praxis direkt neben der uniklinik
heidelberg und das haben sie selber
gesagt es geht um das system war gar
nicht überlastet was ist denn dann die
grundlage an den bewährten
zulassungsstudien vorbei eine impfung
verfrüht zuzulassen mitglied die jetzt
bei den pflegekräften die den aufgezogen
weil ich sage mal einen fall ist
wirklich ich kann jetzt dutzende fälle
hunderte sogar zehn inzwischen ja eine
junge frau 35 jahre als krankenschwester
in der hämatologie in der uniklinik hat
msd hat ms der zwei kinder die es auf
einem auge blind und sie sagt sie hat
noch nie in ihrer abteilung so viele
junge menschen gesehen so viele vorher
gesunde menschen die mit blutkrebs mit
auffälligkeiten immer zwei wochen nach
der impfung zu auf station gekommen sind
und diese frau wird jetzt gezwungen zur
impfung ansonsten würzige künden machen
weil wir da hinten wollen und was haben
wir eigentlich gelernt aus der korona
krise mit blick auf das was wir gerade
erleben auf ein neues virus das sonst
emotionalisiert bei dem wir erstmal
herausfinden müssen was ist das
eigentlich und wir schauen im moment
natürlich auf jedes wort von der
wissenschaft auch hier aus berlin von
den behörden und von der charité da sagt
zum beispiel der virologe leif erik
santer im moment dass er hat sich
ausführlich geäußert am wochenende zu
den ersten fällen die es ja hier in
berlin auch gab und er sagt wir über
beobachten bislang eine disc
proportionale häufung der affen pocken
infektion unter männern insbesondere
nach sexualkontakt zu anderen männern
ich empfehle aktuell besondere vorsicht
und vermeidung von eng ungeschützten
kontakten mit unbekannten personen heißt
dass herr frank wenn wir das hören dass
diese warnung gibt es ja mittlerweile
aus anderen ländern dass schwule
besonders gefährdet sind offenbar junge
männer mit jungen
sexualkontakten auch unter männern dass
die besonders gefährdet sind in diesem
fall also das ist ja völlig in ordnung
dass man den entsprechenden betroffenen
gruppen waren toll dass ihnen sagt was
mir halt immer wieder fehlt und es ist
auch ein allgemeines problem der
gesellschaft dass man gefahren auch mit
konkreten zahlen da liegt also drei
fälle energy wie hoch ist denn die
gefahr eigentlich ja und wir sind eine
gesellschaft die glaube ich kleine
gefahren teilweise aber lassen sie uns
einmal dabei beim warum warum ist das so
offenbar dass vor allen dingen schwule
auch so sagen die behörden im moment
gefährdet ein gut das ist der ansteckung
sweg eben ja und das weiß man wohl und
deswegen macht es sinn diese diese
gefährdungs gruppe d zu informieren aber
das heißt nicht in panik zu verfallen
muss einfach mal gucken wie wie groß ist
das problem eigentlich und das wird hoch
wahrscheinlich nicht groß werden also
das ist das ist ja die aufgabe von von
medizin gefährdete menschen einfach zu
informieren aber man sollte den ton
das soll keine panik schüren weil das
wird wir sind eine gesellschaft die in
angst lebt inzwischen und dann fangen
also leute an die mit paar wochen gar
nichts zu tun haben nur noch mit
handschuhen durch die gegend zu rennen
und da vielleicht sonst die die freuden
des lebens nicht mit rap kurz vor der
sendung mit dem bayerischen
gesundheitsminister mit klaus holetschek
genau darüber sprechen können weil eben
der allererste fall am freitag haben die
meldung rein aus bayern bestätigt wurde
der erste fall von affen pocken hier in
deutschland und das sagt klaus
holetschek bayerns gesundheitsminister
dazu
der erste ja bestätigte affen pocken
fall in bayern bei ihnen vor der haustür
was wissen sie über den zustand dieses
mannes
pro verwenden um mich informiert hat ist
der zustand stabil kaum symptome im
moment scheint sich zu bestätigen was
die genomsequenzierung gebracht hat dass
es sich wohl um eine variante handelt
die auch einen milden verlauf zeitig
sicherheitshalber wurde glaube ich auch
ein medikament bestellt das für die
erkrankung helfen kann aber im moment
wird es wohl nicht benötigt jetzt ist ja
wichtig wie kam dieser affen pocken fall
überhaupt nach münchen überhaupt zu ihm
was wissen sie also über die
hintergründe über die herkunft des
mannes was der zuletzt gemacht hat
naja ich wohl eingereist über zwei
weitere europäische länder hat sich dann
eine woche aufgehalten da war dann wohl
mit symptomen gehabt hat sich dann in
ärztliche behandlung begeben und so ist
praktisch das thema ins rollen gekommen
und dann jetzt zum schluss in die
isolierung in der münchner klinik bei
professor rentner das gesundheitsamt in
münchen versucht jetzt die kontakte nach
zu verfolgen weil das ja ein wichtiges
thema ist und wir haben also die
vernetzungen geschaffen
lgl gesundheitsämter haben die auch
schon mal angeschrieben um insgesamt auf
das thema aufmerksam zu machen ich
glaube wir haben in allen ländern jetzt
auch mehr fälle bekommen es gibt ja auch
aussagen von wissenschaftlern dass dann
eine gewisse dunkelziffer dahinter ist
das heißt sie rechnen im grunde damit
das wir in den nächsten tagen die
nächsten die übernächsten fälle immer
weiter erleben werden
es ist nicht auszuschließen dass wir
mehr dieser infektion und haben sich
vielleicht auch verbreiten es ist aber
so dass wir auch unterscheiden müssen
wir jetzt gesehen in der
genomsequenzierung es gibt
unterschiedliche varianten rotationen
mit unterschiedlichen verläufen und ich
vertraue ich natürlich auch auf die
aussage des lka und der
gesundheitsbehörden die im moment sagen
es ist noch kein grund zu einer
besorgnis dieses thema aber schon ernst
nehmen das nehmen wir ja auch wir können
das ja nicht einfach wegdiskutieren oder
wegschauen ernst nehme heißt aber auch
der verantwortung gerecht zu werden
alles zu tun zu informieren dass
vorsorge zu treffen aber jetzt noch
nicht in irgend eine eskalation zu
verfallen jetzt sagen bisher die
gesundheitsbehörden diese fälle treten
im moment vermehrt bei jungen männern
darauf auch bei fetisch partys in
schwulenbars usw gibt es solche fälle da
steht explizit in diesen warnungen drin
trifft das auf diesen fall in münchen
auch zu
das ist ein thema das im moment
ermittelt wird wo die kontakte
entstanden sind ich glaube man muss da
erst mal wirklich seriös genau
hinschauen es gibt ja jetzt viele
vermutungen auch auf partys im
europäischen ausland das ist schon
wichtig dass man jetzt erstmal die
kontakte ermittelt schaut aber das war
es wohl klar ist dass tatsächlich diese
fälle vermehrt aus diesem bereich kommen
weil ja auch enge kontakte da sein
müssen damit der virus übertragen werden
kann aber ich will jetzt nicht vorab
irgendetwas los treten bevor wenn ich
definitiv wissen wie es jetzt bei dem
ganz konkreten fall war aber das ist ja
insgesamt längst losgetreten also
vermehrt in der schwulenszene vermehrt
unter jungen männern warum eigentlich
das ist glaube ich jetzt ein thema und
eine aufgabe der wissenschaft des zu
klären und vor allem dann natürlich
schon auch die kontakte zu unterbrechen
bzw die kontakte nach zu verfolgen was
wir präventiv tun können das tun wir wie
informieren wir müssen in der
öffentlichkeit aufklären wir müssen für
impfstoff sorgen und wir müssen für
medikamente soll das sind alles
stichworte die wir so kennengelernt
haben wir der korona krise also schon
dieser wir sie auch gerade gesagt haben
herr rittler erleben wir gerade die
rückkehr der pocken nach europa
also ganz ausschließen wird man es nicht
können ich halte es aber für
unwahrscheinlich und ich denke wichtig
ist dass wir
nach verfolgen wie die übertragungs
wege sind wir sollten jetzt auch die
chance nutzen die idee die
gesundheitsämter weiter zu stärken wir
haben vor der partie am anfang der
pandemie den gesundheitsämtern insgesamt
über vier milliarden euro zur verfügung
gestellt zur weiteren digitalisierung
das muss jetzt sozusagen kontrolliert
werden ob das umgesetzt worden ist wir
brauchen einen starken
gesundheitsdienste der in meiner jugend
sozusagen
allgegenwärtig auch in den schulen war
und da haben wir also in den vergangenen
in den letzten zwei drei jahrzehnten den
etwas vernachlässigt und ich glaube dass
das ist wichtig nicht nur für affen
pocken sondern insgesamt für
infektionskrankheiten dass wir einen
starken gut vernetzten
durchdigitalisierten
öffentlichen gesundheit sind diese
maschinerie wieder an wir hören das
schon herr frank also kontakt
nachverfolgung wieder wir setzen auf die
digitalen gesundheitsämter die noch
wahnsinnig weit von digitalisierung
entfernt sind auch nach zweieinhalb
jahren corona krise also jetzt bringt
diese maschinerie auch bei den affen
pocken wieder an gerade über dieses
thema gesprochen dabei gab es ja
warnungen auch schon vor diesen affen
brocken knapp 219 schon von der whu wie
empfinden sie das ja dass er hier wird
über auf dem rücken der gesundheit wird
versucht ganz andere dinge durch zu
drücken da für so eine digitalisierung
durchgedrückt werden das soll
irgendwelche zulassungsverfahren von
medikamenten verkürzt werden impfungen
sind toll wenn sie gut geprüft sind ich
kann nicht einfach sagen jetzt eine
schnelle ecken braven pockenimpfung auf
dem markt nein das musste ordentlich
passieren so kriegen wir so ein desaster
wird gerade bei der m rna cupid impfung
ich finde wir ja sagen sie sagen sie
haben aber ich dachte grad überladen
dürfen ich sage nur ganz kurz desaster
sagen sie weil sie sich so intensiv mit
nebenwirkungen vor allem muss der chef
dann muss man die augen aufmachen
einfach aber ich will nur sagen jetzt
beschäftigen uns mit einem thema und das
was das thema was ihr thema ist es viel
wichtiger war nämlich armut macht krank
und
schlechte wohnverhältnisse machen krank
arbeitslosigkeit macht krank und wir tun
gerade so als würde uns ein satz 5 2
virus bedrohen oder affen pockenvirus
als der schaft bedrohen das stimmt nicht
da werden interessen auf diesem ruhe auf
diesem weg durchgedrückt die mit guter
medizin durch wen ja durch
interessensgruppen da muss man schauen
wie die sind die investoren wehrmacht
karriere mit irgendwelchen themen das
hat alles mit der wirklichkeit ein guter
wissenschaftler nichts mehr zu tun ich
finde das was sie vertreten mit der
allergrößten respekt ist da spielt die
musik wenn man über gesundheitsvorsorge
spricht vertrat ich muss mal passten
auch mal versuchen zu problematisieren
einmal die menschen sind nicht sozial
schwach ich weiß der begriff wird immer
wiedergewählt sie sind sozial
benachteiligt sozial schwach ist der
unternehmer der in bangladesch unter
umgehung der mindestlöhne seine produkte
produzieren lässt ich bin für das eben
von und ich glaube mit dem impfen hat
man sehr viele menschen das leben
gerettet das sehe ich nicht so wenn dann
wieder das typische sie hatten sie
angesprochen was für konsequenzen zieht
die politik aus den erfahrungen lernen
kontext von sozial benachteiligten
menschen und dann wird immer auf
eigenverantwortung auf die eigenen
ressourcen hingedeutet und wieder
typisch keine erhöhung keine
zusätzlichen investitionen in der enns
sozialleistung das ist vollkommen der
falsche weg sondern wir müssen wirklich
hier sehen und da gebe ich ihnen recht
dass armut krank macht um krankheiten
macht das robert koch institut die
zahlen werden mir groß kommuniziert
veröffentlicht schon seit jahren wenn
man das reichste mit dem ärmsten viertel
in unserer gesellschaft vergleicht
sterben arme frauen 4,4 und männer 8,6
jahre früher das ist doch ein skandal in
so einer reichen gesellschaft also muss
hier investiert werden unser
gesundheitssystem muss wieder humaner
gestaltet werden ein zugang für alle und
unser sozialsystem muss eben mehr
investieren in die grundausstattung von
menschen und das in deutschland auch ein
anderes phänomen
arbeitslose menschen da ist die suizid
quote 20 fach höher als bei
erwerbstätigen was macht das mit den
menschen dass menschen ausgegrenzt
werden stigmatisiert werden wenn sie
nicht mehr so leistungsfähig
sind oder auch nicht die chance bekommen
leistung zu erbringen weil sie einen
neuen job bekommen also da sind ganz
andere dinge die verändert werden müssen
und dann darüber die gesundheit zu
stabilisieren um krankheit zu bekämpfen
über das impfen das haben sie beide
gerade angesprochen wollen wir gleich
sprechen weiter auch mit blick auf
dieses neue virus das uns sorge macht
nach ganz kurzen pause zurück bild die
richtigen fragen zu den affen pocken
allein dieses wort das macht uns sorge
seit einigen tagen auch hier in
deutschland nachdem die ersten fälle
jetzt auch eben in deutschland zunächst
in münchen dann in berlin bestätigt
wurden und hier in berlin hat die
senatsverwaltung reagiert auf diese
ersten fälle mit der warnung die uns
irgendwie bekannt vorkommt und sie hat
dazu aufgefordert jetzt vorsorglich dann
wenn man symptome bei sich feststellt
ffp zwei schutzmasken zu tragen was
sagt uns dass herr frank wie empfinden
sie diese erste warnung
jugendwehr hat das noch mal gesagt das
tragen von der senatsverwaltung hier
berlin also wie gott sich an der
offiziellen politik sie ist vollkommen
lebt in der irrationalität ja vom
partner hat mit erosion nichts zu tun
frp zwei masken sind eine schutzmaske
für lackierer für schleifer die sie auch
nur stundenweise aufsetzen dürfen es ist
ist zeigt diese völlige verlust von von
wirklichkeit der der daraus solchen
texten spricht die sich einfach nicht
mehr dafür interessiert was eigentlich
das problem ist und was eine therapie
ist ob die dann wirksam ist oder ob sie
viel mehr schaden anrichtet ob es sinn
macht herr rödl spricht daraus
hilflosigkeit wir fangen sagt jetzt
erstmal ganz schnell am wochenende zwei
fälle in berlin dazu auffordern
schutzmasken zu tragen wenn man symptome
bei sich feststellt also bei den affen
pocken denke ich ist die maske nicht
geeignet diese empfehlung hätte ich
nicht gegeben ich denke da hamburger
eben darüber gesprochen wie sich also
dass wir was hier überträgt und wie
man auch so eine idee kommen kann kann
ich jetzt nicht nachvollziehen geht
meine hilfe wie man auf so eine idee
kommen weil diese maschine eben jetzt
vorhanden weil man das erprobt hat jetzt
über zweieinhalb jahre das bedeutet ist
es im moment auszuschließen also so
schrecklich das klingt aber dass wir
jetzt bald über affen pocken lockdown
uns reden hier in deutschland hertel
also ich halte das für ausgeschlossen
ich
will wissen wie ich am anfang gesagt
habe prüfen ob sich die übertragungswege
verändern nach dem was ich bis jetzt
wahrgenommen habe ist
der übertragungsweg ein ganz anderer es
lässt sich also in dem sinne kein
direkter vergleich mit dem corona virus
herstellen außerdem muss man ja auch
wissen dass also eigentlich alle die
über 50 sind
gegen pocken geimpft sind und damit dass
das interessant einen schutz haben
wollen wir einmal kurz in der runde den
test machen hier erwartet sie sind also
gegen david das sagen gegen pocken gehen
in der runde hat rabatt sind sie geimpft
gegen pocken per fragen ich hab da so
eine narbe ich gehe davon aus dass die
davon starben das heißt sie sind so
skeptisch gegenüber jetzt der korona
impfung damals aber noch dann ja ihrer
jugend oder kindheit wahrscheinlich in
der kindheit also man sozusagen
pflichten gehen man kann gar nicht oft
genug wiederholen um was es eigentlich
geht es geht darum dass wir in
deutschland und wie in anderen
westlichen ländern standards entwickelt
haben um zu schnelle zulassungen zu
verhindern stichwort der entscheidung
war aber auch aus ihrer sicht
ausreichend zugelassen damals geht sie
machen sich glaube ich nicht unbedingt
ja da gibt es ja auch schon auch im fond
aus der zeit ich kenne aber keine zahlen
aber wir haben eben aus der 3 also ich
bitte jetzt mit das ebenso infrage zu
stellen das tue ich doch gar nicht ist
was ganz tolles und wie gesagt ich denke
ihn bei kuoni hat das ist vielen
menschen das leben gerettet ich will
noch ein punkt ist mir noch einmal
wichtig weil wir jetzt wieder
homosexualität schwule es darf nicht
dazu führen dass hier wieder eine
personengruppe diskriminiert wird das
ist mir zu sehr im fokus ja sie werden
so und so schon von unserem staat
diskriminiert denken wir an blutspende
bedingungen das ist eine brutale
diskriminierung von menschen die
homosexuell sind also das darf bitte
nicht sein und ich bin auch nicht jetzt
wirklich also das ist mir manchmal zu
undifferenziert ja fb2 masken machen
auch sind nicht bei affen pocken aber
wenn jetzt wieder aber das aber hören ja
das ist so senat ist brach sagt er trat
nur deswegen reden wir darüber wie ich
das jetzt wieder generell ist heißt das
macht er so und so immer einziehen aber
das ist ein kleiner gemacht vertrag
einmal waren speziell überall gesprochen
und haben uns ehrlich gesagt am
wochenende über diese warnung ein
bisschen gewundert von der berliner
politik versuchen wir an der stelle
diskutiert wissen aber lassen sie uns
beim thema impfen bleiben das ist doch
ein wichtiger punkt hertel wie wir mit
dem thema impfen jetzt mit blick auf
pocken umgehen also in der vergangenheit
gab es die verpflichtung dann ist das
irgendwann aufgehoben worden als ich
noch sehr klein war und sie auch
ziemlich klein waren und mittlerweile
diskutiert man aber wieder darüber
darüber dazu zurückzukehren würden sie
sie gemeint dafür aussprechen der regel
also werden wir wieder eine
pockenimpfung erleben in deutschland
also kann ich mir nicht vorstellen
höchstens dass man andere empfehlungen
gibt für bestimmte personengruppen die
also sich eher mit affen pocken
infizieren können als andere also ich
denke hier ist prävention gefragt aber
keine im verpflichtung aber das ist
interessant für wen denn dann wer soll
sich denn dann impfen lassen also für
wen soll es nicht geben es läuft gerade
wieder völlig falsch herr wurde welche
daten meinen sie also wir wir wir haben
eben wahrgenommen dass also besonders
männer mit häufigen
wechseln von geschlechtspartnern am
ehesten betroffen sind dass sie sollen
unternehmen verlassen hat aber dann sind
wir genau bei der stigmatisierung die
anderen er sagt dann dass homosexuelle
männer immer häufig wechselnden
geschlechtsverkehr wer sagt das ist ein
muss
daher würde sagt es sollten sich die
impfen laden die jungen männer sind
schwul sind oder auch vermehrt
sexualkontakte haben dann muss ich das
ja erst mal auf dem zettel als er wieder
in einem elterliche medizin rein die
geradezu irgendwas ausprobieren probiert
es aus wir haben ist es tut mir leid
wenn ich mich wiederhole und da muss so
unwirklich widersprechen wir haben
standards und es geht wir haben gelernt
in der medizin dass wir mit medikamenten
auch menschen umbringen können ja wir
müssen darauf achten dass das muss
darauf achten dass ein land eingesetztes
medikament mehr einbringt als schaden
und dazu gibt es eben mittel da gibt es
ordnung die studien und so weiter und so
fort und da diese standards wurden bei
der korona impfung gebrochen ich rede
nicht über impfungen speziell sondern
dass diese impfung zugelassen worden ist
obwohl eigentlich wie wir gerade gehört
haben gar kann ich die notlage dazu da
war aber ja erzählt das jetzt passiert
dass in diesem fall das wäre passiert
wenn es über wenn wir jetzt immer puppen
impfungen sprechen dann bestehe ich auch
wieder darauf dass wenn es ist es
wunderbar ich bin vom ist eine
erfolgsgeschichte der menschheit aber
diese impfungen müssen ordentlich
geprüft werden so wie es standard aber
heute großbritannien bestellt jetzt
schon in großem umfang pocken impfstoff
dann wissen sie ob das auch darauf wirkt
also wie wir
haben was impfstoffe angeht größte
sicherheit walten lassen und dass wir
bei corona so schnell einen so guten
impfstoff oder impfstoffe hatten das ist
ein erfolg und hat sicherlich viele
menschenleben gerettet
und wenn man jetzt menschen empfiehlt
bei bestimmten personengruppen empfiehlt
sich darüber nach gedanken zu machen ob
man sich nicht doch lieber impfen lassen
soll also auch gegen pocken dann denke
ich ist das also vorsorge des staates
das heißt ja ist ja keine in pflicht
sondern eine empfehlung dass man sich
mit dieser frage auseinander setzt mit
seinem arzt redet ob es sinnvoll sein
könnte aber ich glaube nicht dass wir
noch mal in deutschland eine diskussion
bekommen über im pflichten über und
setzten sich aus wieder dafür ein und
zwar ab heute dass diese einbezogen
impfpflicht bitte ausgesetzt werde sagen
alle ernstzunehmenden wissenschaftler
die ich kenne sagen man hätte diese
impfung nur für die risikogruppen zu
lassen sollen und auch nur mit ängste
begleiten ich bin mir noch einmal ist es
ist ich muss darauf bestehen es ist eine
bedingte zulassung lesen sie den text
der bedingten zulassung 50 15 07 2006 da
steht drin nur bei einer
außergewöhnlichen notsituationen
strengstens überwacht und ich habe die
impf opfer in meiner praxis die leute
leiden es sind tausende in deutschland
und das sind leute die von chur wird
nicht bedroht gewesen wären und das ist
ein skandal wir werden in zehn jahren in
geschichten und wir drin stehen haben
und dass hier in richtung kontakte
angeht und das muss aufhören ich darüber
reden hier mit dem kaffeekränzchen
drüber und es ist verdammt ernst doch
wirklich zu lassen sind sicher und im
schäden hat es bei jeder impfung gegeben
und man wird feststellen können in der
zukunft ob bei den crooner impfstoffen
dank größerer häufigkeit heute die sind
schon längst da schauen sind
internationale literatur und wir reden
über eine bedingte zu lassen ich glaube
es ihnen selber nicht nein wir reden
nicht in eine normale empfinden wir wir
reden über einen segen dass also so
schnell impfstoffe da waren und ihr die
pandemie so schnell überwinden konnten
das hat doch mit einer impfung gar
nichts zudem nicht politisch
interessiert interessant ist dass er
würde sagt wir werden noch eine
diskussion über eine impfpflicht mit
blick auf affen pocken lich erleben ich
bin mir da nicht so sicher wir schauen
wir mal kurz rein in das gespräch das
sich vor wenigen minuten hatte mit
bayerns gesundheitsminister klaus
holetschek zum impfen mit blick auf
affen pockenviren
dann lass uns über den impfstoff reden
es war ja mal verpflichtet sich gegen
pocken impfen zu lassen das ist aber
schon lange nicht mehr so erleben wir
jetzt die rückkehr der pocken und die
rückkehr der im verpflichtung bei pocken
ich glaube ich nicht wir haben die
pockenimpfung bis zu 180 gehabt und der
impfstoff schützt ja heute noch die
damals gehen geworden sind ich denke man
muss sich jetzt einmal genau anschauen
wie das system ist was für impfstoffe im
moment wirken wirken die da jetzt
eingelagert sind gegen pocken auch gegen
das thema der marke box wie viel sind da
wie lang ist der impfstoff aber ich
würde jetzt auch nicht dass wir uns
durch den wieder von von einer
impfpflicht gleich reden wollen sondern
ich würde einfach mal sehen wie können
wir das präventiv reingehen um auch die
infektionen zu unterdrücken minister die
briten haben jetzt ganz akut reagiert
und haben mehr pocken impfstoff bestellt
ist das was bei ihnen mittlerweile auch
auf dem zettel steht impfstoff
bestellung gegen pocken
das lka befasst sich gerade mit den
experten mit dieser frage und ich glaube
das ist schon wichtig dass wir impfstoff
jetzt auch modern aber natürlich ist
auch in dem fall der bund dran und ich
gehe davon aus dass auch der
bundesgesundheitsminister david de mel
dran geht und sagt brauchen wir was wir
können um gegen kriegen die schnell und
auch das medikament das möchte ich nicht
vergessen haben das dann ja auch helfen
kann wenn wirklich symptome mehr da sind
und wenn die verläufe nicht zu meldete
kein grund zur sorge kein grund zur
panikmache das waren damals die worte
vom damaligen bundesgesundheitsminister
jens spahn hier im studio ungefähr vier
wochen bevor wir dann die ersten
massiven corona ausbrüche in deutschland
hatten das steckt ja alles in unseren
köpfen schließen sie aus dass wir affen
pocken lockdown erleben werden in
deutschland
also diese wortschöpfung zeigen eine
neue ich schließe das tatsächlich aus
ich glaube nicht dass wir auf dem open
log downs erleben werden werden wir im
herbst sie haben gerade selbst gewarnt
die rückkehr dieser gefährlichen neuen
corona variante erleben
das weiß kein mensch wenn sie mich
fragen der austausch mit den neurologen
ist dass er immer schick wir wissen dass
wir denke ich im herbst wenn er in die
innenräume gehen wieder möglicherweise
eine höhere zahl der infektionen haben
möglicherweise kommt eine influenza auch
nochmal mit dazu aber wie die
krankheitslast letztendlich ist und bis
in unseren häusern abzeichnet das kann
keiner sagen sie hören herr frank den
bayerischen gesundheitsminister und
hören auch dessen warnung sehr
differenziert aber hören dessen warnung
hören auch wie er zu einer neuen
lieferung von impfstoff gegen pocken
jetzt steht hören die warnung die er aus
spricht richtung herbst was neue corona
mutanten angeht und wir sprechen hier
über das impfen stellen sie fest oder
glauben sie dass ihre patientin schafft
sich noch einmal aufraffen kann zum
impfen gegen die neue corona mutante
gegen
neue pocken variante also ich befürchte
dass durch corona ein massiver
vertrauensverlust in die medizin droht
weil wir einfach die leute haben dass er
jetzt kriegen dass immer mehr mit weil
wir hier eigentlich das was wir haben
wir haben gute wissenschaft in
deutschland wir haben gute standards
weil die gerissen werden weil die nicht
zu wort kommen wir haben wissenschaftler
die sehr differenziert damit umgehen die
uns die auf patienten schützen indem sie
fortschritte möglich machen aber den
schaden versuchen zu minimieren und wir
haben hier uns angewöhnt über wirtschaft
sagen alle experten waren jetzt
undifferenziert alle wissenschaftler ist
geil doch bei kronach nur noch panik
panik panik und leute die da sehr
differenziert waren wurden nicht
zugelassen na ja und da muss ich auch
mal ich mein es geht doch nicht dass ich
neue medikamente ständig zu lassen und
die gefahren übersee hat übrigens unser
gesundheitsminister auch eine
unheilvolle geschichte finde ich vertrat
sie schüttelt den kopf über herrn frank
ich würde gerne herausfinden
was wir in dieser generation jetzt
erlebt haben generationen corona herr
frank schildert das aus seiner
perspektive jetzt merken wir in dieser
zeit in dieser corona zeit krankheit
gehört irgendwie auch zum leben dazu
nachdem wir alle zeit irgendwie dachten
mensch wir haben das alles unter
kontrolle wir können so viel ist wie
können medizinische wunder vollbringen
und jetzt erleben wir es gibt sachen die
größer sind als wir gegen die wir uns
ganz schwer werden können mit denen wir
leben müssen
das wussten schon immer das leben ist
endlich und krankheit ist etwas
natürliches uns alle betrifft die einen
mehr die anderen weniger die die denen
es besser geht finanziell die sich
besser schützen können besser ernähren
können die haben der höhere
lebenserwartung die die in unserer
gesellschaft
ausgegrenzt abgehängt werden die weniger
gesehen werden die haben eine geringere
lebenserwartung und nochmal zu dem
impfen also ich
wir haben unsere wohnungslosen patienten
informiert und da war auch ein hoher
bedarf sie haben gesagt wann werden wir
geimpft das war gar nicht so einfach
weil wir nämlich dorthin gegangen sind
wo die menschen leben in der teestube
und so also nicht irgendein impfzentrum
und ich glaube wir haben insgesamt 300
400 menschen geimpft kein einziger hatte
nebenwirkungen kein einziger hat eine
komplikation also das muss ich auch mal
betonen natürlich müssen wir jetzt
kritisch selbst kritisch schauen und ja
es muss jetzt auch auf den tisch kommen
wie hoch ist denn die rate der
nebenwirkungen wie viele menschen haben
darunter gelitten aber man muss auf der
anderen seite bitte auch das darf kein
keine dogmatische diskussion sein
sondern das muss eine wissenschaftlich
reflektierte diskussion wollen aber die
tat eine darf nein nicht unterstellen
dass sie das alles nur aus welchen
gründen auch immer gemacht haben das so
geht das nicht sie vermischen sich dinge
miteinander es wird doch gerade nicht
überprüft das ist doch der punkt im hat
vieles wäre das doch jetzt auch
überprüft wurden doch wer macht das denn
derjenige der es macht der hamas wird
diskreditiert das hat das sagt die
realität als staatstragend sein und kann
kritik an der impfung nicht publizieren
also vorkommen also dahin
werden wir werden hoffentlich im herbst
einen an mutationen von corona
angepassten impfstoff bekommen und ich
bin davon überzeugt dass ich eine große
mehrheit der bevölkerung erneut im raum
so dass das ist der punkt herröder auf
den wollte ich noch mal mit herrn
trabert ihn aus weil er ja auch sagt
weil sie uns so schön aus der praxis
schilder dass sie eben dorthin gegangen
sind zu den menschen dass sie nicht
erwartet haben dass sich die menschen
die zu ihnen kommen in die einrichtungen
in den einrichtungen sind das die sich
selber bewegen dass die in die
impfzentren geht sie sind zu denen
gegangen haben dort geimpft würden die
das noch mal machen lassen im herbst
wenn sie dieses angebot wieder bieten
natürlich
gefragt worden wir haben mit johnson
johnson geimpft an jesus das reicht
nicht paion tag und dann sind die
menschen zu uns gekommen haben gesagt
wann werden wir denn jetzt wieder
geimpft ja also da ist ein hohes
bewusstsein eine hohe sensibilität aber
was auch dahinter steht um auch von dem
impfen wegzukommen wir müssen vielmehr
in die stadtteile in soziale brennpunkte
gehen und generell
gesundheitsangebote machen und mehr auf
prävention und gesundheitsförderung
das ist etwas ganz elementares und das
kommt absolut zu kurz und es braucht die
kontinuität des kontaktes um vertrauen
zu schaffen und das bedeutet natürlich
auch ehrlich zu sein auch über gefahren
zu informieren aber die nähe zu den
menschen die erlaubt vieles was nämlich
in der praxis in der distanz und die
botschaft ist angekommen heute abend da
war habe ich ihre leben botschaft ganz
schnell in die runde würden sie sich im
herbst noch mal impfen lassen werden sie
dabei vermittelt sagt ganz große
mehrheit der deutschen der trabert macht
dieselben erfahrung gehen sie davon aus
dass die üblichen ich auch nein
natürlich nicht
diese diskussion gefällt mir gerade
überhaupt nicht mehr weil wir das kommt
rüber weil wir kommen vollkommen an
einer wissenschaftlichen soliden debatte
vorbei reden ich muss sauber ermitteln
wer profitiert davon wer wird geschadet
wohl dass ich es zu wo ist die grundlage
der zulassung und all das ist nicht
geschehen und ich glaube das ist sehr
sehr viele menschen das langsam auch
sehen vielleicht nicht wirklich zu geben
aber im bekanntenkreis sehen dass es
denen nicht gut gehen geht reden sie mal
mit bestattungs- und also sie raten
jetzt an der stelle tatsächlich allen ab
diese empfehlung anzunehmen und sich im
michael thater ist dringend sich nochmal
die eu-verordnung bedingte zulassung zu
lesen und jeder politiker muss dann
erkennen dass die zulassung gestoppt
werden muss und die sicherheitsfragen
geklärt werden also ist das deutsche
verschwörung gegen irgendjemand oder
hören sie mir eigentlich nicht zu ich
hoffe ich glaube aber es wäre absolut
argumente sachlich fachlich ich sage ich
auch nein das genau die gegentore von
emin emotional ja natürlich es gibt eine
das körper einander dass wir bei einer
liga steht also doch ich kann gemeinsam
sondern auch die sicherheits die
sicherheitsfragen sind eminent und es
steht in fünf nur 7 der verordnung dass
daneben evaluiert werden muss und es
wird nicht getan so dies meldeten die
arbeit ist und die menschen werden das
für sich entscheiden wir als politik
sind gefordert neue moderne angepasste
impfstoffe bereit zu stellen die
menschen werden in diesem jahr und in
zehn jahren in 20 jahren immer wieder
annehmen das virus ist in der welt und
wird uns bis zum ende des lebens
begleiten und wir werden wahrscheinlich
jedes jahr wie bei der grippe impfung
einen angepassten impfstoff für rona
bekommen und das ist auch gut so worüber
wir glaube ich nicht mehr diskutieren
sollten ist eine impfpflicht auf allen
ebenen ich denke das ist auch aus der
praxis heraus nicht mehr notwendig weil
damit es schneller strich
verzweifelte pflegekräfte setzen sich
dafür ein dass dieser fragen herr frank
haring klar wir sind am ende der sendung
ich möchte einmal in der einsatz antwort
von ihnen allen hören wo stehen wir mit
blick auf dieses neuartige affen
pockenvirus eigentlich in einer woche in
einem monat werden wir über 100 fälle
über 1000 fälle reden oder gar nicht
mehr darüber herbert ich habe keine
ahnung ich bin da nicht kompetent genug
herr frank es ist ein völlig für die
geführte gesundheitspolitik an völlig
nebensächliches thema mittel
also ich glaube dass wir in einigen
wochen klarheit haben und das dann
darüber nicht mehr gesprochen werden
muss weil sich herausstellte dass die
gefahr nicht ergebnis sagt diese runde
an einem tag an dem der us-präsident
warnt die weltgesundheitsorganisation
warnt danke für diese lebhafte
diskussion hierbei bild die richtigen
fragen da gehen wir sind zurück am
nächsten sonntag
[Musik]